and for alex cobb looking for a long one
tonight wednesday in arlington a variety
of factors kind of conspiring against
alex including a strike zone that was
awfully hard to define
his last two have been short two innings
last time around allowed three in runs
on six hits
alex cobb's warm-up toss is complete as
randy arose arena digs in there's one
and a good start to the night for cod
and that is a splitter from cobb
that's his bread and butter pitch two up
two away and
manuel margot will be the next batter
racked together a modest four-game
hitting streak offering it the first
pitch iglesias has all kinds of trouble
with it and margo's aboard and that's an
error that'll put a two out runner
aboard and so the inning stays alive and
here's brandon now grounding one to the
right side ranging to his right second
baseman david fletcher and he literally
booted it he booted it out to left
center field margot around third he's
going to come home here's the throw it's
not in time into second base goes lau in
the race take advantage of again some
shaky defense by the angels that take a
one-nothing lead here in the first that
ball gets kicked by david fletcher out
into shallow left center field yeah why
stop put the pressure on the defense and
the throw couldn't get there in time
shane mcclanahan set to go to work his
first outing against the oakland a's
four innings two earned runs didn't walk
anybody five strikeouts 59 pitches
pounded the zone
fletcher bounces up to third and wendell
has a hard time finding the handle what
is going on tonight tying run and second
base now with one out here's the next
pitch and that one is going to be ball
four it misses so two of the first three
angels on base runners now first and
second jared walsh will be the next
batter as runners lead it first and
second in the next pitch is swung in a
grounded right side right to brandon lau
he'll scoop on the run and throw to
first and
mcclanahan is able to get out of it by
leaving a couple of angels here's mike
zanino now he's got big numbers against
copper's career seven rbis in one game
against him
got him
couple punch outs with a split finger
change up tonight for alex cobb
looks like a strike ends up just the
lower part of the strike zone well two
men on here's randy or rosarina the
two-strike pitch he got him right there
a splitter struck him out swinging
second time he has struck out rosarina
there's austin meadows leading things
off in the race half of the third full
count three balls and two strikes to
austin meadows
got him looking
that's a little paint with a fastball
from alex cobb here's manuel margo who
started the problem in the first inning
oh got him with it that was a good one
and that's five for alex cobb already
tonight you don't see a batter run back
to the dugout too often maybe in a
little league baseball get me out of
here yes the batter now is the second
baseman brandon lau
got him alex cobb strikes out the side
in the third bottom of the third
underway max dossier the catcher leading
off
and he doubles up
and how about that you know if you want
to go with the change up and then how
about that slider
shohei ohtani is the tying run
and a breaking pitch skied left center
kier meyer is going to be there and he
makes the catch to retire the side
so back to back walks
is zanino
1-1 pitch double play ball
and the angels get them both it's first
and third with two out and here's a
chance for willie adams cobb trying to
get out of an inning in which he has
walked three a ball and two strikes on
adamus
and he got him
the perfect pitch to get him out of
trouble in the fourth now let's see if
shane mcclanahan keep this still a one
nothing game facing mike trout to lead
off the bottom of the fourth
and a cut and a miss
what a pitch by
mcclanahan to strike out mike trying for
strikeouts for mcclanahan i think
they've all been on that slider
you know here's a hundred and then
here's the slider
now we're playing a hand to the move and
throws 2-2 swing on a mess he struck him
out
this ladder tonight is some kind of
pitch
and the batter will be jose iglesias
iglesias first ball swinging into the
gap in left center field and off the
wall
jose on his way into second with a two
out double that just missed tying the
ball game first and second now two out
double and then the walk to upton and
that'll bring up albert
there's a fly ball
toward the line and right over to make
the catch is margot
no runs a hit two left
here's a rosarina
[Applause]
[Music]
dude hit 10 homers in the postseason and
he wants a lead off single baseball that
i want those home run ones
there's a goof going on there's
somewhere there's some information we're
not privy to here
so with the man aboard here's meadows
again the pitch is taking high and
outside a ball throw to second and
that's a ball into center field it goes
trout backing it up and arose arena is
going to get up and he's going to race
for third and he's going to get there
and so arose arena with a stolen base
and the third error of the night for the
angels on the throwing error by max
stassi and now again with a man at third
nobody out move the baseball with a
little authority the infield's back
and a tap out towards second
will
get the run home
picking up the run batted end and it's
two to nothing raise
three singles and a walk
in last night's game drove in a run
scored a run crowded out and walk
tonight
the ground ball base hit through the
middle
trout will return it to the infield
and lead off single
joey wendell
[Applause]
that's going to be out of the reach of
the diving fletcher up to second goes
diaz and
wendell is aboard it's a two nothing
ball game to raise with a couple of men
on here in the sixth inning alex claudio
is on and here's kevin kiermeier
and now ground ball that's going to skip
through the infield
fletcher gave it a wave with that glove
two runs will score
and in the second base goes keermeyer
so the rays now with a four-nothing lead
and how does that ball get through i'd
say the angels had the rays and kevin
kiermar in particular defense pretty
well
and that little chopper somehow snuck
between pujols and fletcher check this
out you got the four outfield alignment
against mike trout when you see all this
smarty pants stuff happening this is
where you just want mike to hit a 100
mile an hour rocket right back up the
middle or just homer
it's just homer
oh get going
get going
yeah put four guys out there put seven
guys out there
he'll hit it over the ladder yeah that
was a majestic home run for trout
his eighth home run
jumped on an elevated pitch and he got
it out hey you needed one more
outfielder to put him in the stands
that's all you needed he's telling
alberto yeah put another guy out there
i'll hit it over him too and in the
seventh inning they will face the tall
right-hander benjamin rowan it is one
and two here to meadows who does have an
rbi round out tonight
this pitch is lifted into deep right
field well tagged and gone home run for
austin meadows that's number six
a one-two pitch
and meadows
makes it a 5-1 game and austin meadows
who homered against him comes up with
2-1 and raised with a chance to put this
game all but away
who gets hold of this one drives it deep
into right center and that one is gone
another home run for meadows on a 2-0
pitch
meadows unloads a three-run shot
and so the power
being very evident here in the last few
days
a home run in the seventh a home run in
the eighth
and the rays build an eight to one lead
so two gone here's bill gosselin who has
grounded out twice and struck it and a
swing and a miss
and that will do it a one two three nine
for strickland the rays win this game
eight to three